[Music]
oh
my god
are you kidding me that one's from me
personally
oh my gosh early birthday gift you're so
nice
gabby
goddammit
[Music]
we just
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't like it at all
i hate this this episode is already
starting off
you know what that is so rude this is my
birthday episode it's my party and i
cry if i want to the disrespect
am i allowed to intro this episode i
think you have to enjoy this episode
i'm crying this is already chaotic i've
already gotten iced within the first
three seconds of walking into the studio
sophia looks like um i'm the birthday
unicorn a birthday unit i'm here to make
all your birthday dreams come true i'm
gonna intro go get it it's my potty and
i'll cry if i want to yeah yeah it's the
birthday episode
yeah round of applause studio audience
no one hey
you got one hand in the back we got one
i have a lot of people here to support
me today
no no
all my friends are here this is like
kind of a flashback of um all of my
birthdays i'm like wow they're just
sophia's friends celebrating me
you're my friend now but back then out
we were
sworn enemies
oh my god well you guys this is steen's
birthday episode
as you can tell it's already a fail
maybe this is a precursor to how her
party's gonna be i am
so happy because i feel like i hate my
birthday typically i just i just don't
like it it makes me really really
stressed out but
this year i'm feeling good i don't know
about you but i'm feeling 24.
i don't know about you but i'm feeling
22. i wish there was a song oh wait oh
no that was the miley cyrus 23 song i
feel like there's always a song with the
number that you usually resort to right
for your birthday there's 22 by taylor
swift there's also there's 23 by sam
hunt
there's nothing for 24 maybe 24 is just
a shitty year
whoa whoa whoa
23 was pretty shitty enough you know how
every year on your birthday you're like
this is my yeah i changed this year i
don't really say that about new year's i
always say that about my birthday i'm
like this is my year for x y and z wait
why do you think you do that more for
your birthday than new year's because i
feel like new years is kind of a reset
and it's a new but it's a reset for
everyone whereas this is more
personalized to you okay so it's about
personal goals what you want to
accomplish i feel like a new year's
resolution is so broad that you really
never keep it mm-hmm my opinion maybe
that's just me i never keep mine
but yeah 24 man i am
going into it with low expectations
therefore low disappointment if i don't
fulfill them what was it that was uh
that zendaya said in spider-man she goes
if you go in with
poor expectations you'll never be
disappointed exactly she said i think
that's such a genius way to go about it
you just won't be disappointed but
normally every year on my birthday i
hate it i love celebrating other people
i love planning their parties i love
buying them gifts that they've i'm a
really good gift giver because i listen
so if you said something six months ago
i'll remember it and buy it for you
that's true but always on my birthday i
just get so funky but i think this year
feels different because
you're one i think your mindset is
totally shifted yes i think you're in a
way better place relationships
friendships career-wise than you've been
before like this is the best you looked
and everything oh your hair finally
doesn't look like it's
between um the um adam's family and um
britney spears it's actually like the
perfect fight are you talking about
britney spears bald or britney spears
you were never bald but like it was
right off blonde kind of almost like my
level i want to say thank you
no you look how fast you look
wow
um thank you
i feel
okay these mini hats don't work no but
you know what and i also feel like
you're
comfortable for what you planned i think
when it comes to birthday parties you
never like your birthday party if you
don't really know what the plan is or
you have an idea of what you want and
you have such a fun birthday plans like
i'm actually really true every single
year i plan a really fun crazy night out
and the problem with doing that is it
just is all relative to what that night
at that certain place is going to be
yeah say if you're going to a club you
could have a great night at a club or
there's some iffy nights at a club and
if it's an iffy night you're like wow
really club on my birthday there's never
been a
like every year my birthday was just the
worst night to go out clubs i feel like
are much more amiss than a hit
honestly i feel like when you're going
to a club it's kind of a gamble of
whether or not the night will actually
be good energy good music like you
really don't know who's there who's
performing unless you have major
connections and you know exactly what's
going on 100 yeah but there is a
birthday tradition that i've held for
quite a few years now do you remember
what it is
i always get a birthday kiss oh yeah i
was just i was going to say that anyway
i know someone you haven't voted on that
i i have not fumbled at all on that one
i don't think you will this year either
there was one year
that um i got catfished on my birthday
can we can we just like really quick
explain this story this was sistine i
think
covid was about to hit or something was
not it was or no it was a actually was
during cobalt no it was before it was
before yeah okay so right before kobit i
don't even know how much you're turning
20.
well oh yeah that's right we're at this
fun restaurant
and sistine had been on a dating app and
she was talking to this guy he's pretty
cute and she hasn't met him yet and it
was
me
um my little sister scarlett sistine's
best friend and that was pretty much it
right yes oh and this girl's
ex-boyfriend and so that was that was
like
white party people in the party
and i don't know how we did this but we
convinced you
yes
you know what on your birthday you look
your best you're wearing your best hair
yeah the best outfit everything works so
you think you know what i'm feeling good
why not and who would say no to you on
your birthday no no one well but we had
to keep up the tradition of the birthday
case so we said i don't see any suitors
around except the one you're talking to
so we invite his ass down and i think
that's a smart thing to do because what
if you're iffy about someone
and you have to waste a whole night on
them imagine if you had gone on a date
with this guy
let me tell you when he showed up he was
cute on the photos
is it
what movie is it from ice age
i always say he looks like the hedgehog
that i don't even know it's a hedgehog i
think it's a hedgehog his name is uh is
it ronnie
ronnie the hedgehog is it ronnie is it
from ice age no it's it's from surf's up
surf's up surf's up surf's up and he had
the spiked up straight hair like dj
pauly d
is it ronnie let me see it make sure
no it wasn't ronnie
raccoon i think he's a raccoon was not a
raccoon what was he
oh he was a boy oh
his name is i don't know who is this man
it doesn't matter if you guys see that
photo
that was our reference that's the
reference photo of him um i can't
remember what his name is but
whatever he looked like the raccoon not
raccoon and surfs up it was and this is
not to be mean but i'm sorry
if you're catfish if you're on a dating
app and
i totally get
for example when i was on one i had a
photo up from like two years ago because
i go okay this one still sort of looks
like me and it's a really cute picture
yeah that's fine but if you have photos
that
look nothing like you today yeah
i'll i'll just see you in court that
should be
okay reggie reggie sorry no but it's
true i won't choose a photo if i was on
a dating app not but
from 2017. even though it's a good photo
i don't walk like that it's not you
that's not me
anyway so i'm so excited about this year
because i'm not trying to plan this fun
thing let the environment make the
outcome of the night i thought
i've been spending a lot of time on
pinterest mm-hmm and i was like you know
what i've always wanted to do
i wanted to throw some sort of
garden
tuscan themed romantic dinner i'm making
the dress code be imagine you are going
to a wedding in tuscany that is the
dress code and i just want everyone to
be drinking wine and eating a lot of
salami and just having a great time i'm
so excited it's so fun and i think that
was the key of why you're enjoying your
birthday this year more yes and it's
because you're not forcing it to go to a
club because i feel like there's this
whole thing where you feel like i need
my birthday to be the most funny
everyone's happy
and the only place to have fun is a
place with music people this this no
honestly at the end of the day
anyone can do that any day i agree we've
got people covered i've got the
ratatouille soundtrack covered but it's
choosing what you actually enjoy doing
and that's why you're calm about it and
i feel like if you're calm going to a
dinner that's good food good drinks and
that's it great leave it at that you
don't have to force this whole thing
like i need to be the most extra because
it's my birthday and everyone else will
like it what do you like if you're if
you like just going to a coffee shop and
getting a a bagel and a i don't know
whatever it's your birthday and that's
it we gotta step it up a little bit
though no but i'm just saying you don't
have to tell you all of your birthdays
you don't have to do the most but if you
like doing the most do it but i just you
know i'm happy you're doing this because
this is such your aesthetic it is truly
it is i'm so excited i'm gonna drive on
this i just want to decorate a table so
bad oh i just like i don't know why i
just want place settings i want
candelabras on the table uh i just want
to look like the music yes oh god
imagine all the music we're gonna put
did you make a playlist set i did it's
not i said it's half started
ratatouille
soundtrack half i found this playlist on
spotify do i buy the ratatouille rat and
just put on the table somewhere i think
that would be appropriate i feel like
that would be necessary yeah that'd be
necessary and then it's half spotify
made this playlist called um
when you're cooking italian food and
it's like a kitchen god i'm i'm ready
ready for it i think people need to know
some italian just so at least we can say
a couple phrases to each other yes you
know just a little bit yeah really good
uh ciao
cuanto cuesta
because uh okay
oh no no is that is that right that's
pretty much it i think as long as you
use your hands felicia
i'm the worst attacker
[Laughter]
yes you by the way why do you sound like
you're german when you speak is that
german
[Laughter]
um no it's gonna be so beautiful and
it's gonna be uh at our parents house
which is gonna be nice yes angelic my
mom wants to rent a horse
she's like we should just make it even
more magical and just have a horse
roaming around the table and i was like
pop off jen castle crazy rent a horse
why not where can you get guy fiery
cooking let's go crazy oh it's gonna be
so much fun and i'm so excited because i
booked a thing for us tomorrow i love
sophia's birthday presents one because
she gets to also have a present for
herself
i am on to you i'm on to you but two
it's something that is memorable every
single year she always says sistine i
don't buy gifts i buy experiences
and i'm like wow that's so amazing one
year she got
tickets on the glass for a hockey game i
mean she always does something really
funny like that but i love sophia
because she includes herself in the plan
which of course i wouldn't want to go
because that's the thing i don't i want
to create memories with her so it's like
fun to say oh we went to a hockey game
on the ice together remember where we
got those jerseys with their names on it
and remember we did this and then this
year yeah i'm stoked yeah i'm so excited
we both have this undying love with
broadway we
just wish we lived in new york solely
for broadway i think that would be the
only reason why i would be there but i
said to sistine we should go to this one
play actually she was bringing it up to
me we saw a poster and i was like screw
it i'm gonna buy the tickets to opening
night opening night opening night and
that's one of my favorite movies pretty
woman the musical
are you kidding me so i booked a
reservation at this really fun
restaurant that's near the place so it
has 360 views of los angeles and then
after dinner we're gonna drive over to
the play and then watch pretty woman the
musical i can't wait it is gonna be so
much fun and i like that it's not on
your it doesn't have to be like near on
your birthday like we're starting to
celebrate early we started today
we're starting today this is your first
month-long birthday yes i would not be
surprised because we're going to new
york this weekend if something happened
even in new york where we celebrate you
again are you hinting that i'm having
another birthday surprise in new york ah
no i probably shouldn't have said that
now they're gonna think that we need to
plan something oh i was excited you brad
i can plan something i love surprises i
hate those people that are like i hate
surprise no no you love them you know
what could be a good birthday surprise
you're going to tell me when the fries
go no no no but it would not a birthday
surprise but it would be really cute so
i think we're considering going to the
mets game on sunday yeah gomez goom i
know nothing about it uh me neither um i
know dodgers-ish and what if a cute
thing would have been like get on the
the cam or you dancing or like the kiss
cam or whatever it is that's my birthday
kiss
on the kiss cam at the mets game
making out with the mascot
the mask of co has to be the mascot what
is their mascot is it like a giant
baseball or something makeup isn't it
mr matt ooh mr mess because it's kind of
sexy i've never heard of this like mr
big have you ever heard of those people
that have fears of uh
yeah what about the people that had a
fear of balloons they'd go crazy in this
room this would not be their favorite
place to be i just noticed that's really
cute it says happy birthday yeah wait
what was another one i was watching um i
was i don't know is it my strange
addiction
is that what the show is yeah
uh well if it's fear it's not my strange
addiction oh well i was watching last
night this woman uh was eating brick
off of buildings have you seen the guy
that loves balloons
wait didn't he like marry a balloon
animal he did he apparently he was at a
dentist that's how it came up to be he
was four years old and i think someone
popped the balloon and then he had this
fascination balloon so wherever he got
barney
no but no no he got yes i think slightly
sad and horny he's a sad and horny boy
when he hurt the balloon pop so since
then i think he's in his 60s now he'll
go to car dealerships that have the
balloons on the cars and he'll rescue
balloons from that are in the sun all
day that are kind of deflating and bring
him to his house and so this is like an
animal rescue
balloons balloons and then it the uh
this is kind of twisted and nasty but
he'll know the exact pressure for a
balloon that is enough to not pop it
while you're poking it
wow that was really good but that was
really gross wait a minute it's really
true you know what though no judgment
there's someone for everyone
you could be in love with a balloon or a
person you like what you like you know
yeah you know you're on a tv show now
for it
something worked he got us five seconds
of fame but i'm anyway back to the
musical um sofia it's kind of ironic the
timing of you booking this because
we watch a lot of tv we get bored with a
lot of things i'm re-watching stuff
right now and sophia called me off the
other day and she goes sistine
you need to go on youtube and watch
legally blonde the musical they have the
whole musical
on youtube yeah and i go this sounds
amazing i start watching and then i stop
and i go what is this next video
i saw a reality show that they made
based off of who gets to play the next
legally blonde who gets to play the next
l woods
let me tell you the best of both worlds
reality tv and broadway mtv needs to
bring the show back it was hosted by
like what's her name not hillary
duffer's haley duff haley duff i mean
and they're wearing such 2000s outfits
with the scarf and the brown boot that's
chunky chunky jewelry so bad but so
freaking good yeah you are obsessed with
obsessed with it like i don't know why
reality shows don't do this anymore this
is real i would love to see broadway
auditions they must be so intense it was
the most intense process ever and those
people weren't even true or were they
all really good broadway stuff they were
trained a lot of them haven't even been
on a broadway stage but they're trained
for broadway exactly okay and sophie and
i are so judgmental we're sitting on the
couch and watching these girls go
through insane trials and training and
hours of dancing and and memorizing
lyrics in 10 minutes and all this stuff
and then they'd go up to perform and
there'd be a voice crack it's if you'd
be like you sucked like like get off if
you can't do a rendezvous or whatever
like a four-step why are you on c yeah
we're like you are not l woods like we
were saying oh yeah i was like this girl
does not yeah i was like she doesn't
give me the energy of l woods she's out
and then they'd be out of like i called
it it but it really does put you in the
best mood it's a musical doesn't lighten
your day mm-hmm
i don't
then i don't know i don't know how
people don't enjoy plays or musicals i
don't actually plays i'm okay with i
think if you're gonna go to a play i
would prefer a musical i think the
musical numbers are just so fun to watch
oh yeah you know a play without music is
just you know because it it's good it's
just a little a play without is it
because it's like
well yeah
it's like
my coffee without the creamer i have
every morning just it works but it
doesn't work
i i'll drink it but i don't like it
it's like a butt without toilet paper
it's my birthday you can't okay that was
a really good one birthday girl um okay
so
um it was funny because i
called mom this morning and we're gonna
speak about like crying on your birthday
and crying in general wait wait you talk
about crying yeah with mom today did you
cry to mom today did you
that makes sense you were quite moody
this morning i was really upset about
the elevators not working yeah she came
in froze it all right i'm just messing a
little bit one of those days oh yeah
yeah
i was pmsing hard yeah you were crying
this morning i was tearing up a little
bit but that it was for a right reason
but honestly since last year you could
tell everything
everything has just been keeping me on
edge edge
what's triggering you babe let's talk
about it but everything okay if someone
doesn't answer quick enough oh my god
they're so rude
feel me and then i catch myself i'm like
why do i i never care if someone doesn't
answer
or
um if there was a fly that i couldn't
catch i just get so angry that this fly
are you an angry pms or an emotional one
i would say more of a frustrated
emotional one i'm i get frustrated that
i have like frustrated tears it's not
sad i just get so annoyed about
something that it makes me tear up which
is very opposite from how i actually am
yes
guys guys are so lucky because
there's always all these jokes like oh
women
don't talk to them when they're on their
period
like we'll bite your head off like boom
you know like we're scary
you have no idea what we feel you know
honestly it's actually no no
you're do you we're scared i'm scared of
my i avoid mirrors i scare myself first
of all you look
horrible it's actually insane within a
matter of week
a week
your skin looks like rumple still skin
you get and look you feel about 10
pounds heavier yeah and you're like what
the hell is going on and then every hair
feels like [ __ ] your nails feel like
everything is [ __ ] and then on top of
that
you think you're scared by my mood
swings
do you think i want to be this person
yeah i can't help it no i really i
actually caught myself and i was so
shocked that i was reacting this way to
something and i'm like i really looked
at my hands like i have
i have too much rage inside of me that i
can't leave
i was i can't leave my apartment today
or else i'll i'll rage oh rage so i
can't call anybody
i don't i don't know just everything
randomly makes sense i was raging
yesterday for no reason mom was like do
you want to go walk the dogs and i was
like
do i
want to walk the dogs
you're
you want me to walk three dogs
by myself
i'm out oh so angry what else makes you
tear up
oh i was and then i get in this crying
phase like you kind of start angry
because you're like oh [ __ ] here we go
again yeah it's first there we go five
stages of grief almost it really is yeah
it's five stages of grief then i sort of
hit that
what is the point of anything what is
the meaning of everything why is there
so much pain and hurt in the world and
why stranger things making me cry right
now and i watched up and i had to turn
it off after the first 10 minutes
because the grandchild scene made me die
you would watch up when you're pmsing
that is you're asking to cry harder from
watching that i didn't even i'm just i
was like oh a cartoon that'll cheer me
up no i had to turn it off when the wife
died i was like you're probably the only
person in the entire world that doesn't
understand that the intro scene in up is
truly the saddest scene but i like to
listen to the animation watch sad things
when i'm sad to make me sad yeah she
likes to listen to sad music write it
out did you i did you ever listen to the
song i sent you glimpses of you it was
weird as [ __ ] you've been in this mood
of like sending don't rage at me right
now i'm a little scared what are you
talking about it's the best i've
listened to it on repeat by j.o.j.i joja
you're really funny when it comes to
music you're like sistine this song is
going to move yeah it does world
you didn't listen to it correctly i
didn't
oh my god you can't give me something
you literally sent me this amazing
emotional song and then the next song
you sent was like a big booty song by
young gravy i'm like which one what do
you want from me right now i like all
genres
you gotta listen to it
sophie and i really love to work power
through things and we often put
our stress on the back burner yeah and i
think also another thing that adds on to
that is when we're traveling especially
right now i mean we're in new york city
and just this whole trip has been kind
of
building up a little bit of anxiety i
don't know
with the work schedule with yeah
managing our family lives our friendship
lives our relationship lives it can be a
lot and it's very stressful and sophia
and i have actually been
using this product that has seriously
changed so much our life and we realize
that
you don't have to feel stressed all the
time and using prima has actually
changed our entire life but i only even
think people realize that 75 to 90
doctor visits are for stress related
issues see that's insane it's insane
because many of us are operating all the
time on survival mode we expect our skin
our bodies our minds to thrive when
we're seriously running on empty yeah so
what's great about prima it's california
we're from california it's a lead
purpose-based cbd hemp product that just
is the best way to relieve stress and
why i love them so much is they are
dedicated to helping you rise above
modern day stress so every day is a
little bit better with their doctor
formulated clinically validated high
performance products for the skin body
and mind so if you're not sure where to
start because i know that when it comes
to these products you're just a little
bit overwhelmed they have daily cbd
capsules that you can just take on the
go to relieve that stress i love these
gummies because you know it's fun just
to take a little bit of sweetness
throughout by the way
delicious it's so good
or you can go at night and you use sleep
tight because i know that she also has
this problem we don't sleep i know we
talked about her od on melatonin this
has been the best
alternative i don't have to overdose on
melatonin congratulations
has literally given me some of the best
sleep of my life so
lucky for us prima is offering our
listeners an exclusive limited time 20
offer with the code unwaxed trust us
because i feel like you guys are
convinced at this point so head to prima
dot co and get that 20 off using the
code unwax and get the relief you
deserve by using the products today
[Music]
i i don't know i just need to chill out
i've decided that today and the rest of
the week until i'm chill i need to avoid
human interaction good to know
so we won't get dinner tonight i'm
actually we're canceling tomorrow
i can't go to a place so i'm going to
pretty woman alone on my birthday yeah
and dinner well
another year around the sun
whatever to change up topics um i
thought this was crazy because we talked
about this and i think this is genius
and also
the worst thing that could happen with
iphones um update you can edit your text
and you can delete your text this that
you already see is so
fantastic for women i guess in all
people in general
why
there are so many benefits to this new
iphone feature you can edit a text once
you've already sent it and you can
delete a text once you've already sent
it now
if you're
you know what's really funny though i
was explaining this to someone the other
day and
the fact that both of your brains just
go to the same point of like oh this is
gonna be a bad idea yeah when really the
intention of it was so that if you wrote
a typo instead of having to correct that
word you can correct it everyone's mind
goes to oh we can use this as a
manipulation tactic or yeah anything
involving relationships it has nothing
to do now with just the fact that it
saves time i could go off on one of my
pms rages
start rage texting yeah unsend
everything and say
show me where where are the receipts
where are they there's none yeah there's
none i know they're genius next you're
gonna edit a phone call because you can
you can do that on instagram you can
unsend something you can't edit the
message i mean it's already been said
fantastic it's pretty genius yeah i
think it's so exciting because i'll
always you know sometimes i'll give you
the wrong time or the wrong date and
then i'll go back and fix it
now that's not very nice it's so small i
wonder actually could you
still edit after you send something and
let's say i responded you can still edit
that's i feel like it should just stick
with it after you send it and then i
respond no don't give them that idea but
i don't you think that's a little bit
more fair because then that's
going to
how do we use this new tool as
reverse psychology as manipulation so we
can you know yeah with the conversation
it's so good well your mind kind of goes
there a little bit more you're talking i
didn't refresh i didn't i didn't think
about manipulation or toxic 24 baby
you know actually speaking of like toxic
girl summer whatever louisa have
i actually think this year is fully the
opposite
i do too it is not really hot girl
summer i do too i feel like you know i
learned so much about myself when i turn
23.
just about
who i am what i want i feel like you
were right i kind of got myself settled
i don't think there's not much you're
still a baby i'm still a baby but i
understand myself so much more than i
did and every single year i'm like oh i
figured myself out but really i did not
know the person that i was and
it's really interesting like i just
don't for 24 i just don't want to care
as much mm-hmm and i think you know
having our last previous guest we had
maria menounos and serena kerrigan and
they have the same train of thought that
you are the reason
that something in your life that you
want to happen isn't going to happen
like you put up mental walls you're the
one telling yourself you can't do it
you're the one that stops dreaming
because you say it's unrealistic and i
just like don't want to care anymore you
know what i actually it's so funny this
morning i saw his tick-tock and i
thought it was such a good explanation
for i think how a lot of people
especially in their 20s are feeling um
and you know how when you're in your 20s
a lot of the time you feel like i'm
behind i need to be here i need to i
need to have my job figure out my job
figured out why aren't i comfortable
where i'm at and this girl was like
if you put it into perspective and
you're let's just say your 20s are your
first years as an adult right
you are
let's just say
four years old in adult years i'm only
five years old in adult years wait a
minute do you see what i'm saying 25 are
we caught in dog years no i'm confused
no actually i'll try i'm trying because
i'm not it's not that hard to figure out
you're 24. okay let's say your 20s at
the start of your adult year i see so
yeah four so you're foreign
don't put so much pressure to have
everything figured out if you're only a
four-year-old four years old in like
adult years and for me five years old
and it actually kind of made me take a
step back and go
oh my god if that's if i'm not saying we
get lazy or like stop slowing out but
i shouldn't also expect everything to
happen all at once and the odds of me
having everything figured out like
another person that's in a different
position than me
that started when they were 12.
see the thing i appreciate about being a
child
is that
you had
dreams
and you had ambitions and you had ideas
that you wanted your life to be
without doubting yourself that those
were unobtainable
and you also didn't
care how you were going to do it you
just truly believed that you were going
to get it and then as you get older that
idea just sort of withers away and
you're like oh well that's unrealistic i
can't do that because of x y and z
um there and that's fine it's still
important to have priorities and
realistic goals yeah but
i mean that
no and kids don't care about you know
how they look all the time and how
they treat people they're just wanting
to be happy and have fun and
no and serena kerrigan said um
and this was actually kind of went viral
because it's such a good way to put it
she said
if you weren't ready the opportunity
would have been not there for you
so the opportunity is there for you
because you're ready the opportunity to
come
if you weren't ready
so take it even if your mind is telling
you you aren't you know what i'm saying
and that just changes their perspective
like if you're saying you can't that's
just your own insecurity you wouldn't
have this chance to
take this leap if it didn't present
itself yeah i totally agree whenever i
it's always nice to talk to someone
that's older than you and they've been
through it and they understand life a
little bit more and
whenever i ask mom about
you know she keeps it real in terms of
like if we want to try this or pursue
that
but in terms of like following your
heart and following your gut and
following your head
the thing that i love hearing from her
is she goes
why not like why wouldn't you do that
why wouldn't you take a risk and go on
that trip with that person and
be just happy and be in love and wear
your best outfit and not stress about if
it's going to work a month or two yeah
like what's the point i know she always
says with your outfits like when you're
overthinking it she goes when else are
you going to wear it
if it's an extra i mean what else like
who else
it's not about that i don't care i just
don't want to care as much i know i just
want to do things for me i want to like
wear my hair and stupid pigtails like a
four-year-old because i like the way it
looks and i'm not gonna worry about what
other people think yeah i think we all
need to have a
subtle reminder that don't put you so
hard on yourself and do the things you
want to do honestly and try to try it
try new things you know what i tried the
other day
and i was so anti this i hate hiking
i would rather get a root canal than go
on a hike she really does i hate it
but i had this one friend in town he
always loves to go hiking so i was like
all right only for you i'll go hiking
let me tell you it was the best time
ever i told myself for all these years
that it sucks that you'll get dirty and
it's gross and you're sweating and
there's like a fly stuck to your boob
like it just is the worst worst outcome
ever yeah you're dusty but it's fun yeah
and i thought it was so interesting
because
when you break sort of out of that
mental routine and you do something sort
of different for yourself you might be
surprised what you like and don't like
yeah like i was convincing myself for so
many years that
this i would tell you that so many
things
for but like you like to
read every single day x amount of pages
because that makes you feel good and i'm
like i would never do that i would like
i don't want to spend my time doing that
but i guarantee you if i did and i would
tell myself i didn't like something it'd
probably be really amazing for my mental
health no it's true even like with
workout classes that you're intimidated
to try because you think these people
are so good at it and they have the
great bodies and i know cece always
talks about like orange theories she's
obsessed with that class love that class
um
it is a good class like i was so against
it i don't like group classes that much
and i did it and i was like okay like if
i was doing this more consistently i can
see myself actually enjoying this it's
just stepping out of your comfort zone
it really is true but
it's important to force yourself to say
yes yeah it is and i had this epiphany i
always complained especially when it
came around my birthday that i didn't
have a lot of friends and all my friends
were out of town it was really hard for
me to find a group of people i could
celebrate with and so majority it would
always be your friends and scarlett's
friends and mom and dad and me and that
was fine i still had a lot of fun but i
was always like like i wish i had you
know a few of my friends or whatever
and then
the past week
i started getting messages from old
people and um
and it felt really good and the old me
would have said
no i'm too tired no i feel bloated
i just already ordered takeout i want to
stay in i would find a million excuses
why i shouldn't go but then i realized
if i don't say yes to these things
they're not going to keep inviting you
out yeah and i remember they want you
there for a reason no it sometimes when
i you guys can use this if you want if
i'm hesitant about going somewhere and i
really don't have a legitimate excuse
i'll look at myself in the mirror and go
why not
and then i have to look at myself and
give it actual reason right like
yourself
why not is you're tired
okay
you're gonna sleep seven hours tonight
you'll be fine if it's a friday you're
sleeping saturday yeah oh wait your
workout's gonna be pushed okay also you
don't have to drink
yes no one's forcing me i've been
working on that i know you were always i
was a ba humbug when it came to drinking
yeah she was a bah ham book about i love
anything involving going out let me tell
you it's tuesday right now it's tuesday
i've already had
four margaritas this week
thanks guys
but no she really tried and
the thing you guys are probably like if
she doesn't want a drink she doesn't
have to and that's very valid and you
don't have to do anything you don't want
to do but your reasoning for not wanting
to do it was not the right reason to not
do it you know it wasn't like
i didn't like being drunk because i love
it it wasn't that i didn't like the
taste or whatever i just didn't
think that i deserved to feel
hungover with no you know it's like she
had ambition that actually she had this
always hang anxiety which everyone gets
after and she just puts so much pressure
on herself like i have to look and be
and act perfect and then you're out and
then you're still not feeling
comfortable because you're still trying
to put this persona on that you're oh
trying to pierce over but as you always
tell me no one's honestly looking at you
and gabby told me this the other day no
one honestly cares what you're saying
what you're doing or how you're looking
except you like i even when i post a
story i'll overthink that as small so
i'm glad that you're like loosening up
about all this stuff because look what's
happened honestly it can a week of just
having that consistency and i think the
biggest thing that you guys all need to
work on and i need to work on and she
does is not needing someone to tell you
to go for it yourself you need to learn
how to go for it yourself learn and
train your mind how to say yes to
situations and yes to new opportunities
rather than having to call your mom your
friend your sister because they're going
to be times where they're not around you
and you can't get a hold of them and
you're going to have to sit with
yourself make the decision so true is
whenever you feel like you've had a hard
year like i thought 23 was probably the
hardest year i've ever had
i would not take it back and i would not
change a thing and i would not change a
decision that i'd made because even
though i was feeling my worst
it gave me the opportunity to sit alone
with myself and that is the only way you
can truly decide what you wanted who you
want to be yeah and i'm so grateful for
that and it took yeah in the beginning i
would say for you it took maybe me
sistine
me scarlett and mom saying a couple
times why are you not saying yes to this
why are you being so hesitant and now
because you've said yes four times
you're so
it's easy but it starts with you it's
like
you could tell me until the coyotes came
home yeah and i still wouldn't want to
go so this year 24 i hope you guys join
this bandwagon with me we are releasing
some of the pressure we put on ourselves
i'm joined giving a [ __ ] and we're just
gonna have fun what is that fun act
first think later
yeah do it for the plot
for the plot do it for the plot if
you're worried about going out you think
it's gonna be shitty do it for the plot
we should talk about um
very traumatic experience our little
puppers went through the other day oh
my god and gabby was there as a witness
producer gabby was here
in person for it
it was horrible so um i'm at the house
with the parents inside and it was me
gabby and scarlet outside by the pool
and all the little doggos are running
around and they're having fun and they
usually love to chase lizards as you
know if you guys don't know what they
look like they're the psy they're like
um
they're they're caterpillars they're
small they're small dogs they're not big
dogs they're a little bit bigger than a
pomeranian i'd say and the biggest one
is maybe a size of a beagle
so we're sitting there talking and we
turn around because we hear rustling
from the back of um
this bath house or bathroom whatever
that's near the pool
and a dog whimpering and we see from
around the corner our two dogs billy and
buster and a
massive
coyote when i say massive
i've i've lived around coyotes and we
have and they've always been kind of
skinny because that just shows they're
not that well fed this one no he's lifed
up beefed up it was a giant german
shepherd looking coyote my dad said he'd
never seen such a big coyote in his life
i
lost my mind
one of our dogs billy the smallest one
out of three of them my favorite was
crawling towards me low whimpering like
she's been bit limping i think she had
been maybe picked up or something by
this coyote and like it traumatized her
so she instantly ran towards us this
coyote i think was stunned it could have
two seconds turned around in bitbuster
or billy i'm pissed
and it freaked out because me gabby and
scarlet were shrieking screaming the
screaming is what's safe it's a dog's
life it stunned it yeah and it the worst
part was buster
for some reason this dog i love him to
death but he's i don't think he's very
smart he's so stupid he chases the
coyote as it runs away he wants to play
and i'm losing my mind thinking i'm
just lost my favorite dog ever i do a
favor sorry buster is my favorite and i
think everyone knows that
and i just have never been so scared in
my entire life it's traumatized and that
coyote i can tell you for sure and by it
was not that far for me it's from here
to where this camera is or maybe a
little bit farther than that
easily could have ran up and attacked
one of us
no doubt it would have ended me
unfortunately this isn't the first time
that we've lost an animal to a coyote
this is the second time there's two
times we've had this happen yeah
three times
three living in the hills they come
right into your backyard in the morning
when you let them out and i want you
know it's not like all in a row that
we're like boom boom boom
in 25 years i've been alive we've had
three but really and it's horrible scary
and if you're watching this coyote
i'm not coming for you i'm coming for
your family first
and then your little hole where you
sleep in
and then i'm gonna take every fur you
have and pluck it off one by one okay
torture the coyote and make
socks out of it i would just say please
please if you live in an area with
coyotes be so careful they bark like
dogs on purpose to get your dog to come
up to you and they go in packs that's
kind of smart though no they do you
always hear them barking in the hills
well
don't we kind of do that i mean i'm not
saying we bark what do you mean they
change their voice to attract someone
we gotta do this are we coyotes i'm just
saying they're it's not far off i mean
come on when you're flirting with a guy
your voice doesn't go up 10 octaves it
doesn't change with a guy changes with
service
whenever someone orders my food i go hi
can i please have salmon can i slam it
with quinoa please look at my everyday
order because i'm healthy
what'd you say about the neighbor's dog
oh this was so funny speaking of dogs
and you're going to lose your mind so
prepare to be lost i
was taking out the trash and we have
this trash sheet on our floor
and this woman comes out of the elevator
with her
i don't we used to have pomeranians i
don't love pomeranians but this one
looks like a mix between some mutt
pomeranian it's so cute so hyper runs up
to me is licking me loves me i'm petting
it i'm like oh my god you're so sweet
and literally it just kept it just
stayed with me the owner kept calling it
the dog wouldn't leave my side and when
i was walking to my door
and i would be pissed if i was the owner
yeah like pick a side i raise you and so
i would cl i like
kept petting him like you should go go
go the owner lives down the hall i go
inside my room and i hear scratching on
the door because the dog wants to hang
out with me so i'm saying oh my god i
wish i could just steal the dog uh so
then a week goes by
and i run into the lady again with her
dog and she was oh god you know since
that my dog has met you it always stops
at your door and scratches wanting to
come in june print on it wait listen to
this and um she goes it's just the dog
is obsessed oh my god that's so sweet
and she walks me she goes
bambi
oh
that's your name that's my name
oh
you guys have a connection we have a
connection
maybe you're the mom i said that did you
give birth to a pomeranian didn't know i
feel like i could have because i feel
like we look alike a little bit blonde
definitely blonde but like natural
brunette yeah
just like blonde from the side
but the dog is named your drunk name yes
if someone had a cat in my hallway it
was like tina that dog that dog's energy
that dog's energy was me when i'm a
little tipsy
just hyper kind of like a little bit
dizzy when i come to my birthday i
should actually see did i just i'm upset
the dog barks all the time and usually i
should be annoyed by it i don't care
it's bambi it's my dog
i've already done this
that's your neighbors seem fine though
no she's so nice mine smoke so much pot
did you see that email because they've
been smoking on my floor oh oh that
makes sense i'm like right above you i
think it's me just toking no i don't
think it's you but it makes sense why
it's really strong in my apartment
that's so annoying it is really
frustrating there's nothing worse than
having
bad tenants live next but then again i
think i'm a bad tenant or tenant is it
tenant yeah i think i'm a bad tenant to
live next to because why they hear
musicals all day oh no for me mine is my
smoothie maker and it's not a quiet one
it's
like 7am oh my god are we are we the
drama
i don't think we're the drama why not
the drama or else drama
but i love that dog so to wrap up this
birthday episode i thought it'd be
really fun if we did a five question
birthday trivia of the year since he was
born 1998 and see if she actually gets
any of these five questions of when she
was born so it's my birthday
but i don't know if you're gonna get any
of these but it's pretty interesting
this one's kind of hard but
what do you think the population was in
the u.s
in 1998
i don't know
all right
what tv show made its first debut
popular popular tv show
i'm gonna guess in 1988 friends close
seinfeld
closer
is what's the you love the one you love
the show i love this show
it has a group of people
women
group of women
it's not when you know the answer
a group of women
in the 90s
and you love sex in the city there we go
okay
next one
what do you think the most popular
birthday gift was in 98
can you tell me if it's a it's an animal
it's an animal kind of an animal like a
fur
for a coat
you got the first part of what it
actually is called a f fur
hat
no it's an animal
a furby yeah wait what yeah i was
kidding it's a furby the most popular
gift in 98 was the colony blink at
different times all right i hate those
this was the biggest movie of 98 and
it's still one of the biggest movies
today it killed it in the oscars and i
to if you want a hint let me know but
it's a romance
romance and it involves your biggest
fear
swimming
swimming romance titanic
yeah ding ding ding i love this game all
right we have two more oh my god who was
people magazine's hottest man of the
year in 98
hottest man of the year is it an actor
or singer
actor actor
was he in
notting hill no
he did uh many action movies he only
does action movies many mostly fiction
movies yeah
was it something like bruce willis
on the right track i'm never gonna get
this um tomb raider
tomb raider
indiana jones
i don't know his name
harrison ford harrison ford
i don't know
i don't know okay
there's a question that's a
scene we don't even
guess usher all right this is bush
98 yeah all right last songs last one
last one okay thank god oh my god
britney spears released the song in 98
and it's still one of the most popular
ones today hit me baby one more time
that was easy okay
we love brittany we love britney
[Music]
and i think that is a wrap
goodbye 23 hello 24 thank you guys so
much for tuning in to this week's
birthday episode
with special guest me featuring sophia
and guys please remember to submit your
unsolicited advice onto apple podcast
give us that five star and please leave
a review because it actually does help a
lot and i think if you're listening to
this all the time it really shows us
that yeah that's the only thing i want
for my birthday reviews yeah she doesn't
want anything else i'm not going to get
her
okay bye guys we love you love you next
tuesday
[Music]